[Music]
welcome back to Las Vegas now Easter is
approaching and Chef Jeff from Smith's
Food and Drug the sponsors of this
segment is showing us how to make Easter
soda glazed ham steaks check it out
happy Easter everybody I'm Chef Jeff
from Smith's I'm gonna go out on limb
and say you're probably gonna have ham
for your Easter meal right and if not
that's awesome too but if you are and
maybe you only have two people in the in
the house and you don't want to buy a
big hammer so I've got a recipe to help
save the day the ham steak it's a
wonderful thing and in fact you can do
this for a crowd too so it doesn't
really matter for a small group or a
crowd that's what makes this recipe
great but these ham steaks are like four
dollars and there's two huge ham steaks
in there but I'm going to show you how
to make a soda Glazed version of that
ham steak super easy to make super
delicious gives you all those flavors
and you don't have to throw it in the
oven and wait it can be done within
minutes really so what I'm going to do
is I have those packages come with two
ham steaks in them they're pretty thick
Great Value in those I love them but
what I'm going to do is I've Got My Pan
over medium high heat what I'm going to
do is add some butter to my pan and then
once that butter melts I am going to get
my ham steaks in there and then Brown
them on both sides is what I'm basically
what I'm after I'm let me get the ham in
there
and it takes probably about three or
four minutes per side but we just want
to get a nice Brown on our ham steaks
okay so let's get our ham out of the pan
they're nice and brown be careful when
the ham cooks too because it likes to
pop a little bit and splatter just be
careful with that okay
ham is out we just want to get it brown
on either side and then now we're going
to start our glaze that's going to be
soda so you can use any kind you like
I'm going to use black cherry you can
use Cola Root Beer whatever you prefer
I'm using black cherry and then in next
goes Brown Sugar
some Worchester Shire sauce this is
super easy things you probably already
have and then some honey just about a
tablespoon or so that's about right and
then I'm gonna let this come together
and just kind of boil down just a little
bit maybe for about four minutes or
until it starts to thicken just a little
bit and then we're gonna get the ham
back in there and then we'll have thanks
or Thanksgiving we'll have Easter dinner
already within minutes so it's a great
little recipe
okay so after about three or four
minutes it's
reduced down a little bit and got kind
of a little it's gotten a little thicker
what I'm going to do now is to whisk
some butter into it that's gonna kind of
stabilize the sauce and make it a little
bit more rich just makes it better
butter makes everything better right so
I'll just stir that in really quickly
take just a second to melt it
my butter is melted in now and back in
goes my ham steaks I just want to put
them back in there just for a second
just to get that glaze stuck on both
sides so let them cook on one side and
then we will flip them over let them
cook on the other just for just a minute
or two just to re-warm them and then
dinner is served and minutes later
dinner is served super easy to make
let's get our ham steak on there I'm
gonna serve it with some mashed potatoes
and and asparagus get some of that glaze
and put on there maybe even put some of
that glaze on the potatoes why not it'll
be delicious you can find all these
ingredients at your local Smiths thanks
for watching me for shopping happy
Easter everyone we will see you next
time bye
for this recipe and more visit this
website
smithfoodanddrug.com now